-Guys, like I said,
the Super Bowl is this Sunday
and, man, it's going
to be a good one.
You got the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers
taking on the
Kansas City Chiefs.
You got Brady versus Mahomes,
Kelce versus "Gronk."
Both teams are so great,
it's nearly impossible
to predict
who's going to win.
But you're in luck, because when
it comes to predicting things,
we have a secret weapon,
and it's puppies.
That's right --
ladies and gentlemen,
it is time for the
"Puppy Predictors,"
Super Bowl LV edition!
-♪ "Puppy Predictors" ♪
♪ "Puppy Predictors" ♪
-Alright, here's how it works.
We have one bowl
of delicious kibble
and two adorable puppies --
one representing the Bucs,
the other representing
the Chiefs.
Now, let's meet the puppies.
♪♪
Hey. Hey.
That is -- Hey.
Hey. That is rude.
Gary, Gary, don't put
your back towards me.
Gary. Thank you, buddy.
I appreciate it. Thank you.
There they are.
First, we have Ron Bell
representing the Chiefs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ron.
And then he'll be taking
on Gary Frick Jr.,
representing the Bucs.
All right, guys,
before I release you,
I need you to listen up, okay?
No. Hey, Ron, guys,
this is a competition.
Gary, wake up. Let's go.
Now, look, no wandering.
Thank you for paying attention.
No peeing,
no butt-sniffing, okay?
This is professional.
This is a professional game.
We want to see who wins
the Super Bowl.
Okay, here we go.
Get ready to go.
Alright, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
Okay, now to predict who's
going to win Super Bowl LV,
here are the puppies.
Release the puppies.
♪♪
No, no, no, no.
Absolutely not.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, guys. Absolutely --
Oh, yep, it's a tight game.
They're back in the game.
Here they -- It's going to be
the Buccaneers!
[ Dinging ]
You did it! You did it, Gary!
Good job!
Congratulations to
the Super Bowl champs,
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.